BUT. HI GOOD MORNING THE RULES
COMMITTEE IS CALLED TO ORDER
PLEASE BE ADVISED THAT AN AUDIO
AND VIDEO RECORDING IS BEING
MADE OF TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS AND
IT IS ALSO BEING TELEVISED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ATTENDING
THIS HEARING ARE ENCOURAGED TO
WEAR A MASK AT ALL TIMES
ATTENDEES MUST ALSO REFRAIN FROM
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING.
VIOLATIONS OF THESE RULES MAY BE
SUBJECT TO AN AND SUBJECT AN
INDIVIDUAL TO REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY
WALDRON HERE SENATE FLORA FONG
GIPSON THERE LEVY MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS RUBIO THE VALLAPUDUA
REFORM. WE HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE
A CONSENT AGENDA IS THERE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA.
CAN HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY WALDRON HI WALDRON AYE
BENNETT FLORA FONG FONG AYE
GIPSON- GIPSON HI LI LI AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS MATHIS I RUBIO RUBIO IV
BOUDOIR. THE BUDDHA MOTION
PASSES MOTION PASSES. WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AJ
ARE TWENTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN THIS AREA BEING
PRESENTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. MISREPORTING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS AREA AND I STAND
BEFORE YOU TODAY ASKING FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON AJ ARE TWENTY SEVEN
WHICH COMMEMORATES AND HONORS
THE THREE MILLION VICTIMS. MORE
THAN HALF OF THEM ETHNIC
ARMENIANS WHO WERE
SYSTEMATICALLY KILLED AT THE
HANDS OF THE TURKISH OTTOMAN
EMPIRE THEN THE REPUBLIC OF
TURKEY. FOR YEARS THERE HAVE
BEEN STATEMENTS OF DENIAL THAT
THE GENOCIDE I DIDN'T HAPPEN
THIS WAS AN EVENT THAT WAS WELL
RECORDED BACK IN NINETEEN
FIFTEEN AND BEYOND EVEN BY THE
UNITED STATES AMBASSADOR AT THE
TIME. AND YET EVEN TODAY THE
LEADERS OF TURKEY DENIED OF THE
GENOCIDE EVER TOOK PLACE AND YOU
WILL HEAR SUCH TESTIMONY
POSSIBLY IN THIS ROOM EVEN TODAY
. THE RHETORIC THAT USED
SOMETIMES IN TURKEY IN AROUND
THE WORLD BY GENOCIDE DENIERS
IS. NOT JUST FACTUALLY
INACCURATE IT DOES IT'S NOT JUST
THAT IT DESIGNERS. THOSE PEOPLE
WHO LOST THEIR LIVES BUT IT'S
ALSO DANGEROUS BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT DENYING GENOCIDE. LEADS TO
EVEN MORE GENOCIDE AND LEADS TO.
LEADERS TO ACT WITH IMPUNITY AND
TODAY WE SEE. SOMETHING SIMILAR
PLAYING OUT IN YOU IN UKRAINE.
WITH RUSSIA DENYING ATROCITIES
EVEN WHILE THE WORLD WATCHES. SO
I THINK THAT THAT SHOWS WHY THIS
RESOLUTION. THOUGH IT MAY HAVE
BEEN ABOUT AN EVENT THAT
HAPPENED A HUNDRED YEARS AGO IS
SO VITALLY IMPORTANT AND I WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. SECOND
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN OTHER
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
STE HE'S ORDER. OKAY SING NO
SUPPORT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FORWARD AND YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU MOTHER
NATURE AND MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS CUT ON
MATHIS. I AM A PRESIDENT OF THE
TURKISH ALLIANCE IN CALIFORNIA.
I HOPE WE YOU KNOW HAD THIS
CHANCE TO READ AND EVALUATED
DOCUMENTS I GAVE IT TO YOU.
HUMAN BEING NATURAL BEHAVIOR IS
RESISTANCE TO CHANGE MARK TWAIN
STATED I QUOTE IT IS EASIER TO
FOOL THE PEOPLE THEN CONVINCED
HIM THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN FOOLED
. WE HAVE BEEN ACCUSED OF DEATH
ACCUSED OF DENYING ITS SO CALLED
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE. THE
INTERNATIONAL COURT REJECTED
ARMENIAN REQUEST REQUEST TWO
TIMES ON THE SUBJECT. JOSEPH
GOBLETS HITLER'S PROPAGANDA
MINISTER. HE STATED. I COURT IF
YOU REPEAT REPEAT LIE OFTEN
ENOUGH PEOPLE WILL BELIEVE IN IN
THE END YOU WILL EVEN COME TO
THE BELIEVE IN AN EXTRA SELF.
FORTY SEVEN TURKISH DIPLOMAT HAS
BEEN MOTOR BY ARMENIAN TERRORIST
T. OFTEN IN CALIFORNIA. NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE GOOD ANY OTHER CAN
INVITED TWO TICKETS DIPLOMA TO
LUNCH HE SHOT AND KILLED BOTH OF
THEM WHY THE MEMBER BY THE DIED.
THE HUNDRED DIFFERENT WAS A LIFE
AND YET HE CAN'T LIFT A
CIGARETTE AND WATCHED HIM TO DIE
. LATER GOING DICK MY CHEN.
PARDON ME ON A KEY. ARMENIAN FOR
IT IS BROUGHT SCHOOL CHILDREN
COULDN'T GET A CAN GRAVES AND
PRESENT THIS MOTORS IS A HERO TO
THE CHILDREN. NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO HUMPING SESSEGNON ASSIST NAY
THE TURKISH CONSULATE CAME OUT
ARTICLE IN LA. ARMENIAN FROM OF
THE POSTED KIDS TO GIVE THE
TICKET BACK MONIES TO SASANIANS
LEGAL DEFENSE. NOW SOCINIAN IS
RELEASED FROM THE JAIL AND HE'S
LIVING IN ARMENIA. IF YOU ANY
KI<c.cyan> INCESSANTLY UNVEILED BLACK</c>
BROWN OR POOR WHITE GUY IT WOULD
BE ON THIS FEDERAL. FORTY SEVEN
TURKISH DIPLOMATS WERE MURDERED
BY YOUNG CANADIANS WHO NEVER HAD
EXPERIENCE WITH TOUCH ID NOR DID
THEY KNOW THE SUBJECT. THEY
COMMITTED MURDERS JUST BECAUSE
THEY WERE BRAINWASHED BY THE
ARMENIAN GASPARRO. I DON'T KNOW
IF IT'S INTENTIONAL OR
COINCIDENTAL APRIL TWENTY ONE IS
A VERY SPECIAL DAY ARMENIAN
HISTORY AND TOUCH IT BEFORE US.
ON APRIL TWENTY ONE NINETEEN
FIFTY A GROUP OF ARMENIAN JOIN
THE RUSSIAN ARMY AN INMATE AT
CITY OF ONE. THEY MUST SECTORS
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
CIVILIANS MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN
IN ONE DAY. DURING THIS TIME
THEY MUST I COULD FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND CIVILIANS. DURING
THIS TIME SUCH AS THE ARMENIAN
SO FOR THIS BOOK RESHOOT
SYMPATHIZE WITH ARMENIAN
SUFFERING. A RESOLUTION LIKE
THIS HIS IS NOTHING BUT HATE
PROPAGANDA IT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH ARMENIA OR WITH GENOCIDE.
AGED TWO ONE SEVEN AND PREVIOUS
SALUTE RESOLUTIONS DO
PARTICIPATE TO PERPETUATION OF
HATE PROPAGANDA MY GOAL IS TO
STOP PERPETUATING HATE
PROPAGANDA. SO CALLED ARMENIAN
GENOCIDE GENOCIDE RESOLUTION
BECOME HOT COMMODITY IT IS
STRICTLY A SERVING ARMENIAN
DIASPORA POLITICAL AND PERSONAL
GAIN. IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
ARMENIA OR RICHTIGEN. BEFORE YOU
VOTE ON H. H. R. TWENTY SEVEN
ASK YOURSELF WHY I'M WANTING TO
SUPPORT. LOOK AT MY EVIDENCE IN
MY DOCUMENT THE SUSPICION IT
BECAUSE OF THAT IT IS BIAS DO
YOUR OWN RESEARCH AND MAKE YOUR
OWN CONCLUSION AFTER ALL. YOU
ARE LAWMAKERS AND YOUR DECISION
SHOULD BE. BASED ON FOUGHT NOT
FICTIONS BECAUSE YOUR ACTION
WILL AFFECT SOCIETY IMMENSELY.
PLEASE VOTE NO ON THE RESOLUTION
STOP PERPETUATING HATE THANK YOU
. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
QUESTIONS. HELLO THE SECOND.
OKAY SO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. COOLEY WALDRON AYE
WALDRON AYE BENNETT FLORA FLORA
HI FONG FONG AYE GIPSON GIPSON
AYE LEE WE AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS MATHIS
AYE RUBIO RUBIO I'D BE APPROVED
BY THE APPROVED BY THE FOR
PROFIT. THE MOTION PASSES. WE
JUST YEAH- ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLOOR
ON CONSENT. FLORA HI. CAN THIS
WAS WORTH COMMITTEE ADJOURNED.